Americans saw a dramatic increase in
robo calls from scammers this year
despite regulators efforts to crack down
on the problem the Federal Trade
Commission says the Social Security
Administration is the number one
government agency targeted by scam
artists in the first half of this year
people filed nearly 73 thousand reports
of social security imposters reporting
losses of 17 million dollars
consumer investigative correspondent in
a Werner is here with us now with more
on this and a good morning first of all
I hope you had a good holiday I did
thank you this has not been good for
people we were just talking about it we
all get these calls why are we seeing
these social security calls now and why
so many you know if we could ask the
scammers we could ask them why are you
using so scary scam and we don't really
know for sure but my guess is because it
works they try to scare you frighten you
they say the police are coming to your
house they say you need to give us your
social security number it's been
compromised so they're either after your
personal information which you don't
want to give them or your money and you
know why giving that either yeah I guess
they're finding out that it works but
this is something to know that nobody
from the Social Security Administration
is gonna call you so what should you do
when you receive one of these calls
because you hear time and time again
people thinking they they said certain
things that they knew who my cousin was
all right look the US Marshal Service is
one of the entities that is getting you
know spoofed and faked now right and
they're saying to people look if we need
to talk to you we're gonna come to your
house with a badge right and we're gonna
say hi in person and say we're gonna
show you our identification right
they're not gonna call you up and espect
the US Marshal Service made the point
they said we are not going to give you a
warning that we're coming so what do you
do hang up okay
block the number and then you can report
it to the government if you want to help
them sort of figure out the trends it
runs out do that much for you personally
but you should call the FTC the FCC you
can report to the FBI if they're
imitating US Marshals there we've got
the links on our website where you can
go to report these things but in general
you know a lot of it I think a lot of us
are playing avoid the phone call yes
I do too yeah it definitely feels as if
the FCC is saying look to the to the
American people you've got to be on the
lookout for this and that is certainly
true but I think people would say well
as the FCC doing enough to protect me
you know that has been a question going
for several years now right I feel like
we keep coming back to this at least
twice a year and saying what's happening
what are they doing the phone companies
with the encouragement of the FCC are
putting into place something they call
shake and stirrer which is a standard
and basically it's supposed to go after
some of this and the spoofing where they
make calls look like they're coming from
your mom or your neighbor or your
next-door neighbor but they're working
on it but you know what it's really not
solved yet so unfortunately in the
meantime it's up to you the consumer to
watch out and you know what's really is
angering is the people that they go
after who think that the police are
really coming at right right you know
your mom your grandmother you know your
elderly friend and not just old people
but some young people who get scared
they want to panic you don't panic when
they call hang up the phone it's really
the best advice Social Security
Administration is not going to call you
if they say it's about Social Security
you just hang up does that National Do
Not Call Registry work because it seems
like since that's been out there it
hasn't done anything so that works for
the legitimate telemarketers the real
businesses guess what the scammers don't
care right it's what they're doing is
illegal anyway they don't care hmm I say
you talk back to them too siren in the
ear could work I don't know thank you so
much
you